(basketball sounds on court)
- [Man] One.
- [Gary] Five.
It's five.
- [Man 2] Good shot.
- [Man 3] Board, board.
- [Man 4] Good shot.
- Gonna be serious if you
really, really, really seriously
got crazy about your
mid-range jumper
you'd have 15 years of
happiness with your ball.
(Upbeat music)
Mom, mom, when are we
going to get you as a guest
for an #AskGaryVee Show?
- [India] Yeah!
- I think it's time.
I know when I do that
it's just kind of like
fuck please do
this for yourself.
Please let me will
you to this place.
- Yeah.
- I'm there.
- I don't need anything.
I desperately want you to
because the thing I get from it
is you telling me thank
you and I feed off of that.
And when I hit that in
a video that's when I
most feel it.
I think of it as more of a
self fulfilling prophecy.
It's why I'm pushing everybody
for comments and feedback
because it feeds me.
- [India] Yeah.
- It feeds me.
It's like laughs.
That's why I try to be funny
on stage or get reactions,
like I can build, in my talks.
Most of my talks unless
something weird happened.
I am a funny guy, right?
- [India] Yeah.
- DRock, you think
I'm a funny guy?
- [DRock] Yeah.
- I'm a funny guy.
- [India] He hesitated.
I jumped right in.
- [DRock] No, I had
to get the camera.
- [India] Now it's
always a competition.
I'm sorry.
- [DRock] You won, India.
Forever and always,
you won the contest.
- That's right.
Don't back off of that.
Be like yep.
- Yep.
- That's how you
stick it to people.
People are always like, "You
won," and I'm like, "Uh-huh."
And they're like...
- Yeah.
- When they try to be
condescending, "Okay, you won."
I'm like, "Yep, I sure did.
"I won directly in
your fucking mouth."
Good, Marcus, how are you?
My man.
- What's up brother?
How are you?
- Good to see you.
Let's do it. 211?
- [India] 211.
- Hey everybody,
this is Gary Vaynerchuk
and this is episode 211 of
The #AskGaryVee Show.
- This was great, man.
- I love you.
- Dude, you're so smart, man.
- [Marcus] Gary!
- Love you. Talk to you soon.
India, where's the car?
- Your gift can
be to give back--
- That's what I've been doing.
- to small entrepreneurs.
- We need to spend
some real time together.
That's what I'm
doing in parallel.
- Hi.
- Hi, I'm Stacy.
- Stacy, I'm Gary.
- Nice to meet you.
- Nice to meet you, how are you?
Really well.
Chef, I appreciate that.
I will talk to you soon.
Hello.
- Hey.
- How are you?
Good.
What's up Snapchat?
Go check out my Facebook
account right this second.
One of the more important videos
I've pumped out in a long time.
Check it.
I'll go speaker
for DailyVee crew.
This is fun.
This is one of my favorite
things I've been doing since
back in '08, '09 just give me
your number and I'll call you.
It's an amazing opportunity
to connect with peeps.
It's just a lot of fun.
Doing fun stuff seven minutes.
Can check email got a lot of
work to do, no question, but
this is where you make decisions
about your community or your
execution or filming here,
you're always making decisions.
You're always
picking different things.
It's a mood thing.
There is no right answer.
I'm not right with my style.
But everybody's
got their own thing.
Let's see what happens.
Manuel?
- [DRock] Daniel.
(phone rings)
- [Daniel] Hello?
- Daniel?
- [Daniel] GaryVee!
You're really calling me?
That's awesome man.
- I'm really calling you.
How are you?
- [Daniel] Good, man, good.
(inaudible)
Listen, I am really glad you
called because I had an
idea that I wanted to do a meet
up with fans of the show and
I reached out to Brandon at the
Wine Library and I was like,
"Hey, can we use your
spot as a venue maybe?"
And he pushed me over to Tyler
and I haven't heard back from
Tyler yet. This is only
the other day--
- Yeah.
Poor Tyler is drinking
out of a fire rose we're getting
thousands of emails a day.
He's just starting as
an assistant and
he's killing it by the way.
- [Daniel] Okay.
- We'll take a look at it.
I'll talk to Brandon.
Send me an email directly
Gary@vaynermedia.com
and I'll take care of it.
Alright?
- [Daniel] Alright, cool.
I appreciate it.
- No worries, man.
- [Daniel] What can
I do for you, man?
I already own an #AskGaryVee
book but what can I do for you?
- I'm good, man.
What you can do for me is say
thanks and I'm gonna call some
other homies.
I hope you have a
great day, brother.
- [Daniel] You too, man.
- Bye.
(phone ringing)
- [Andrew] Andrew Fulliato.
- Andrew, this is
Gary Vaynerchuk.
- [Andrew] Hey Gary,
how's it going?
- Super well and you?
- [Andrew] I can't complain
just working away.
- I love that.
That's always a good thing.
Everything well in your world?
- [Andrew] Pretty good.
Just a year into my business now
had a tough getting to the month
but it's all picking back
up now which is good.
- Don't think of it as
month-to-month when
you're only a year in, man.
It's a grind. You know?
- [Andrew] I know.
Basically I do consulting for
another company too and they had
a software that was supposed to
launch in February and it got
delayed 'til May and it just
made me of doing 100 hours a
week between the two.
- Yeah. Tough.
- [Andrew] Some of my clients
in my other business I ended up
having to like not give them
as good a service as I
should have--
- Of course.
- and a couple left
at the end of the month
which is completely
understandable.
- Listen, man, the ebb and
flows and the ups and downs.
If it was so easy
everybody would do it.
Keep grinding.
What do you do?
- [Andrew] I do
digital marketing for
real estate agents.
- Good for you man.
Good luck to you.
- [Andrew] Thanks.
Appreciate you calling.
- No worries, man.
- [Andrew] You're a
huge inspiration, man.
- Thank you, man.
Take care.
Nate? Nate from our office?
My former intern?
- [DRock] Yep.
And then my former assistant
and now one of the
key cogs to VaynerMedia?
- [DRock] Yeah.
- That Nate?
- [DRock] One and only.
- Let's see if he answers.
(phone ringing)
He has time to be on Twitter
but not answer the phone?
- [DRock] A buck
says he doesn't answer.
- [Nate] Hey.
- Nate?
- [Nate] Did my tweet work?
- This is Gary Vaynerchuk I
see you wanted me to call you.
- [Nate] Yeah,
this is excellent.
This is very efficient of us.
- Yes.
Do you need some help?
- [Nate] I have a
couple questions.
- The questions that
can be on DailyVee?
- [Nate] About creative staffing
and decisions you need to make
in terms of marketing.
- Good so no
we'll edit that out.
Hold on one second.
Go ahead. What's up?
Sorry everybody, Nate
stole everyone's time.
Just a bad guy.
- [DRock] God, Nate.
- Not me.
(ukulele music)
♫ Well, I know this waiting's
no good for me ♫
♫ but it seems
to be a remedy ♫
♫ it seems to have me
write my little songs. ♫
♫ I give you love
like a giving tree, ♫
♫ place you in my melodies, ♫
♫ to try and bring you back
where you belong ♫
- Oh thanks man.
- Big fan.
- Thank you, man.
What's you're name?
- Mike.
- Mike, nice to meet you, man.
- I see your
videos everyday, man.
- Thank you, bro.
- It's inspirational.
- Thank you so much.
- Energy is real.
I'm not going to lie.
- Thank you, man.
- I'm not gonna lie, dude.
- Thank you, brother.
I wish you well.
(ukulele music)
♫ See us forever ♫
♫ doing nothing together ♫
- My man.
- Hey, my man.
Good to see you.
- I'm psyched to be
up there with you?
- How've you been?
- Great.
- All well?
- Yeah, very good.
Very good.
- Great to see you.
What's happening,
you're fireside chatting me?
I love it.
- I've got some Q&amp;A's
and I'll let you rip.
- You've seen, you know how I do
so you're going ask questions,
I'm gonna rip and then we're
going to go into Q&amp;A with them?
- Yeah.
- Love it.
The most showmen and bravado
version version of myself on
stage when the lights are on
and people are looking at me.
In my navigating of my
businesses, I've been much more
a tortoise in a hare's costume.
I look the part but I've
been very calculated, I've been
obnoxiously patient when you
really look under the hood.
I'm sorry that the world is
changing but it is and I think
that I don't have a whole lot
of empathy for laziness and
dwelling and just settling in
because it's just a
losing mentality.
I think what's ended up
happening in my life is
I day trade attention.
And what I mean by date trading
attention is when your marketing
or trying to tell a story
whether you're trying to be the
president of the United States
or raise money for your NGO or
your bake sale at your school
or sell bottled water or whether
you're trying to accomplish in
life, first you need somebody's
attention and then
you need the creative
is the variable of your success.
There's a very big difference
between being a branding and
marketing lead engine
and a sales lead engine.
Why did I buy these sneakers?
I didn't buy them because Nike
fucking cookied me on a website
and re-marketed to me
and I finally gave up and
bought it on their site.
I have no idea why I bought
these and that's what
branding and marketing is.
You like that one?
- [Chris] I love that one.
- I'm like Khrushchev.
It's my Russian DNA.
These are really nice.
- [Man 5] Yeah, the
artist did awesome.
The best part is you
don't have to sit.
- [Woman] She'll be doing
exactly what I'm doing now--
- Awesome.
- for the books.
- Setting it up.
Awesome.
- (mumbling) Nice to meet you.
- Finish, finish.
- I brought a banana for you?
- Oh, you did?
- Big fan.
- Thank you, man.
I appreciate it.
Thank you, real pleasure.
Awesome.
- [Man 6] Thank you, Gary.
- Thank you.
Thanks for having me.
Thank you.
- [Woman 2] And we're here.
- Well, this is nice. Jesus.
Is that our new building?
- [DRock] Yep.
- That's our new
building, right.
- [Woman 2] Let's get signing.
- Okay. Let's do it.
Wow, this is really nice.
- [Woman 3] Right?
- I feel like I don't
want to leave.
Can I just sit here and
sign 1 billion books all day?
- [Woman 2] Yeah.
- It'd be fun.
- [Man 7] I don't want
a signed book,
I just want to
say nice job, man.
- Thank you, brother.
- Thanks very much.
- I appreciate it.
- I met you before and
I appreciate it too.
- My pleasure.
I hope you enjoyed it.
- [Man 7] Absolutely.
- Thank you.
Nice.
DRock that harness is legit.
- [DRock] It is.
- We're so ghetto I need
to get you a harness.
- [DRock] Cool.
- Cool.
- [Man 8] While Staphon is
really awesome editing,
I love DRock.
- Staphon's coming on.
I love it.
I love competition for DRock.
It makes me happy.
- [DRock] We all are.
- Thanks, man.
- My pleasure.
- Thank you for everything.
- I have multiple business
one Snapchat account.
Do you recommend funneling
it all into one Snapchat?
- Yeah, you know why yes?
Because I think you start with
Snapchat it's going to be a lot
of you and you start building
the narrative of you
and your business.
- Then it funnels
into everything else.
- I think you should do one big
rant right now of like here are
my business and
here's what they are.
It's like an established piece
of content, download that story,
put it on YouTube, have
something to point to.
- Yeah, cool.
- Cool, you got it.
Get outta here.
- Yeah, I'm Phil.
- Yes, I remember from London.
That's right, man.
This I didn't remember
that this was the talk.
That's awesome, man.
How are you?
- I'm really good.
(inaudible) amazing by the way.
India and Garrett.
- Yes.
Thanks, man.
I hope you enjoyed the talk.
- Yeah. It was great.
- Thank you.
- Hey Gary.
Nice to meet you, man.
- How are you?
- Been watching you for a while.
Did one a long time ago.
Can we take a picture?
- Yeah.
- Thanks, man.
- Awesome, man.
Real pleasure.
- I appreciate what you do, man.
- Thank you, brother.
I wish well. Good luck to you.
Hi. I noticed.
Thanks for the nice vibes.
- Oh well good, yeah.
- It's always good to have the
people that gives you some head.
- Could you write to
Jan in here for me?
- Of course. J?
- J-A-N that's it
short, sweet and simple.
Really enjoyed it.
- Oh!
- Just cross off the E out.
- J-A-N? Just A?
- Yeah. No E.
- No E.
- No E. That's the
story of my life, no E.
Hey, I love it.
- Awesome.
- Thank you so much.
- Such a pleasure.
- I very much enjoyed it.
- Thank you so much.
- You're inspirational.
I do want to get the
audio for sure though.
- Thank you.
- 'Cause I'm like
you though, reading?
- I'm not good at it.
- I lose the attention.
- Me too. Me too.
- Listening, no problem.
- That's awesome.
Really nice to meet you.
Take care.
- All right, Instagram.
- Let's do it.
Hold on, let's get this.
- That's awesome, man.
Real pleasure.
- Yeah, man.
- Real pleasure.
Thanks for the love.
Awesome.
- So dirt is what you do
every day to get something.
- 100%. That's right.
And actually, I handle all
my social media accounts.
I look to the data,
I do it and then
thus I understand it better.
- [Man 8] Right.
- I think people just get
too far away from the
work eventually.
- Right.
- And I think the humility
that's needed to deploy that is
a very big
competitive advantage.
- Tyler Lawrence.
- How are you, my man?
- I had to say
man Scottie Pippen.
I'm from Chicago
so that hurt me.
I wanted to stand
up and crush you.
- I understand.
I understand and he's an amazing
player but I think people
misunderstand what having
that Alpha, that real Alpha.
- Anybody could have been.
- Everybody.
Everybody in my wine business
was the greatest at what they
did in the wine
business until I left.
You know what I mean?
- Totally get it.
- And Scottie had enough years
of body of work in Houston and
Portland to prove me wrong.
So I feel very comfortable
with my point of view.
(laughter)
- Totally understand
as real well.
- I respect it.
- Real pleasure.
- My daughter she's number
one in the country in fencing.
She's going to Europe.
- Wow.
- Can you write--
- Yes.
- to Morgan good
luck in Budapest.
- M-O-R-G-A-N?
- Yeah.
- That's amazing.
How old is she?
- She's 15.
She fences in Brooklyn.
- [Gary] Is she literally
like Olympic potential?
- Yeah. She's basically, yeah.
- [Gary] That's crazy.
- She's got three
Olympic coaches,
she's had three
Olympic coaches, yeah.
- [Gary] Good luck, man.
That's really cool.
Hey man.
- Jason.
- Nice to meet you.
- How are you?
- Can I get a picture to put
on social media and online?
- Yes, of course.
- Alright let's go.
- Awesome, man.
- Thank you.
- [Gary] Real pleasure, Graham.
Stay well.
Ready DRock?
- [DRock] Yeah.
- Let's do it, David.
- Reverse it.
- We should probably do that.
- Love it.
Thank you, my friend.
That was fun.
- [DRock] Yeah.
(light music)
- [Gary] You know let me preface
this by saying I know nothing
about martial arts.
But I know a whole
lot about business.
And I do know enough about the
common sense that the momentum
of your opponent is
something you take advantage of.
Fundamentally, I want to
expand on what that means.
Obviously you saw that great
interview with that little guy.
- 'Sup my man?
- GaryVee.
- How are you?
- Good.
- Good. What's your name?
- Alejandro.
- Alejandro, nice to meet you.
How old are you?
- 10 years old.
- Love it. Hustling already?
- Mhmmm.
- Love it.
- Okay, so the first question
that I was going to ask if I was
your son and I'm
starting a business--
- Yep.
- what advice would you give me?
- That's a very, very
solid opening question.
I would know you since you
were my son and I would look at
everything that you're
interested and the first piece
of advice I would give you
is do something around that.
So for example let me
reverse this on you.
What do you love
besides business and
things of that nature.
What else are you into?
- Karate.
Why do you like
the New York Jets?
(laughter)
How do you think you're going
to lead up to buying them?
- I don't know how I'm
going to buy the Jets.
I don't.
- You don't?
- I do not.
I know that I, by nature as a
businessman, am a counterpuncher.
What I mean by
that is oh, karate.
Do you do karate?
- Yes.
- I don't know this because I've
never done karate but what
I hear by being a common sense
individual in the world is a lot
of martial arts is predicated on
using other people's energy
as your offense, right?
- Yes.
- Good. That's who I am
as a businessman.
I'm the best.
I think I'm gonna go down as one
of the best karate businessman
of all time because what I'm
extremely good at is responding
to the actions of the market and
then finding my opportunities.
I never thought that I would
be producing content,
that I would be in
to social media,
that I would
have an agency,
that I would write books.
I reacted to the opportunity.
Got it?
- Yeah.
- There was no plan.
The plan was pay attention
to what's going on,
find the opportunity and strike it.
Yeah, I mean I'm starting
to really understand
that that's what I do well.
Sometimes I talk about
riding the wave and I talk about
counterpunching and I wanted to
go a little bit deeper for all
of you, that's what this
whole DailyVee project's about.
Not just the headlines or the
quotable comments but
go a little bit deeper.
I think it's very
powerful to ride a force.
I'm sure martial arts and its
pretty understandable and boxing
use the other person momentum
to set up what you want,
riding a wave.
I talk about technology running
you over unless you ride it.
That's how I think
about business.
You take momentum and you figure
out use it to your advantage.
I don't predict.
I don't go on the offense.
I'm not trying to force VR or
social media or e-commerce.
I often talk about not selling
to somebody who can't be sold.
Anybody that doesn't understand
that we've evolved every day
forever always and forever.
Everybody wants
the world to stop.
You know everybody wants the
world to stop for their
vested interest.
- [Man 9] Right, right.
- You don't like
that's it happening.
Your job may be in jeopardy.
You're worried about your kids.
It doesn't matter.
Technology is
gonna do its thing.
You know, this all
ties in together.
Right?
This is going to be
interesting for a lot of you,
I'm not the aggressor.
I'm the one who takes
on what's happening.
What I'm doing is a
whole lot of watching.
I'm watching these people who
are walking the streets,
phone culture.
Phone culture.
People on their phone.
This is real, this
is not super hard.
I'm really just absorbed with
what are people actually doing
and then how do I react to that.
I don't have any wants or
needs that they're
actually doing that.
I'm not trying to force
people to start doing that.
What I'm doing is I'm reacting
to what people are actually
doing and I do think from a kind
of religious and here's a good
opportunity when I say
"religion" I mean strategy.
Right?
From a religious point of view,
from a strategic, which would be
the way the most people say it,
from a strategic point of view
this is what I'm
trying to figure out.
How do I take behavior
that's already happening,
how do I then bring
the most value to people
in something they're
already doing?
I'm just sitting here and
watching people on their phone
it's just the way I
see people doing it.
I see the world
very clear almost.
It's like those movies, you know
those sci-fi movies where they
show it from the perspective
of that character and they see
different things, I kinda
weirdly think that's
what's happening with me.
That I feel like I'm
seeing different things.
Once I make that strategic point
of view that religious point of
view I then go pot committed and
go all-in and figure out how to
use your collective momentum to
create the opportunities for me
and my partners.
That's what my life's about.
I didn't discover email.
I didn't create email.
I wasn't an email advocate.
I knew that you are using email
so I figured out how to
sell you wine in it.
I didn't create Facebook videos.
I didn't invent it.
I'm not an advocate of it.
I know you watch it.
So I make them.
And so that's how I see the
world and that's what I meant by
reacting to people's momentum.
In martial arts, in fighting,
it's your opponent,
the other person, for me as a
businessperson who thinks at
scale to try to build
big businesses,
it's done on a market level.
All of you.
(light music)